George did your second or was that
actually there to begin with no I was
raised Catholic and at in Catholicism
that at the age of thirteen you undergo
what's called confirmation where now
that you've reached the age of adulthood
thirteen you confirm they vows that your
godparents took for you during baptism
and you also to say a confirmation name
in extra names so I took my cousin's
name and that became my second or but it
was a pretty pretty boring name that so
the RR I thought it was really cool and
I started using it on my aunt it's my
fans in the stories but there are a few
very early publications of mine with
only 2 1 R which was were probably
written before the age of 13 before I
was confirmed and I had that second
second or two to add to it I'm always
fascinated by the way but the
confirmation think there's a you know
sometimes I get critics or people who
object to my characters being so young
they're considerably younger in the
books and they are in it in the TV
series we had to age them up for for
modern reasons a modern sensibility is
then but it was very different in the
Middle Ages and and you know you there
are still there are still legacies of
that would that we can see in modern
religions like Judaism with its uh
what's his Bar Mitzvah ceremony today I
am a man at age 13 and Catholicism with
its confirmation ceremony today I will
take as an adult of 13 I will take these
things so you know we still have the the
heritage of an age in which children
grew up a lot faster and we're expected
to take on a lot more adult
responsibilities than modern
certainly children in both of your books
grow up very fast and it seemed to me to
be really nice people but some better
fault
put your characters and your readers
through hell you kill your characters
off you torture them you treat them
badly
are you really both of you psychopaths
under this man I'm good to send that one
to you George first I'm going for it to
the answer of this let's see I could
have written a story about a really
well-adjusted family in a well governed
realm where Ned Stark comes down and
takes over and solves all the problems
and the Seven Kingdoms that was a great
period of prosperity and Danny is
welcome facts and married off to you
know one of the other noble families for
the realm and you know occasionally
there's a currency crisis or something
but I don't know would you guys have
been having a conflict and and conflict
in danger and all of these things are
the strong spices that we want you know
when it would occur in our real life we
hate them but they're part of what makes
life life as opposed to just unending
days of boredom and I think we we crave
them in our in our fiction so George
taking a scythe to the characters
because of the plot or because you've
grown bored with
we'll just like them what to torment us
well I mean my books are structured with
a very limited third-person viewpoint
but I have a large number of viewpoint
characters who I switch between to tell
the the entirety of the story but that
does limit someone who I can kill
because sometimes there's something only
one character who's my eye in a
particular patient or a particular camp
and if I kill that character then I'm
gonna have to introduce another
viewpoint character in that camp or
possibly everything going on with that
particular subplot is going to be off
stage and my remaining characters are
going to hear about it through the
conveniently arriving Raven
as much as I like Ravens a succession of
chapters where people read particularly
interesting letters about battles court
another press of the kingdom would
probably bring down my editor's wrath
upon me enough of the Raven letters so I
do have to keep keep the new point
characters in where they are and when
they're gonna be needed and when
something major is gonna happen with a
particular storylines I need a pair of
eyes and ears to to tell that that
thankfully is getting a little easier
with these last two books because you
know the the structure of my books kind
of everyone was together and then they
all went their separate ways and the
story has dealt it out but it's it's
finally reaching the point where it's
starting to dealt it back in and the
viewpoint characters are occasionally
meeting up with each other now and being
in the same point at the same time which
gives me a lot more flexibility for
killing people
[Laughter]
[Applause]